AHEAD AND GET STARTED WITH OUR
HEARING THIS AFTERNOON.
A COUPLE OF ANNOUNCEMENTS BEFORE
WE BEGIN -- WE WE WILL HERE --
TWO WITNESSES PER SIDE WITH A
TIME LIMIT OF THREE MINUTES EACH.
AN ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WILL BE
ASKED TO STATE ONLY THEIR THEIR
NAME AN ORGANIZATION AND THEIR
POSITION ON THE MEASURE -- THERE
ARE NO BILLS PROPOSE FOR CONSENT
FOR TODAY'S HEARING.
OUR FIRST AUTHOR IS WE ARE WE
WILL BE OPERATE AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE AS WE HAVE -- A FEW
MEMBERS MISSING.
THE FIRST AUTHOR TO PRESENT IS
SENATOR BELL AND WHEN HE'S READY
PLEASE COME FORWARD SIR.
CENTRE BELL WILL BE PRESENTING
TO BILLS.
THE FIRST IS SB -- TWELVE ITEM
NUMBER ONE IF THAT'S WHAT IF
THAT'S OKAY THE SENATOR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
THANK YOU.
FOR HEARING SB TWELVE THE YOUTH
DROP IN CENTER BILL.
THIS BILL ESTABLISHES THE
INTEGRATED YOUTH MENTAL HEALTH
PROGRAM.
WITH THE GOAL OF ESTABLISHING --
YOU'VE DROP IN CENTERS.
ACROSS THE STATE.
NOW MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES ARE
AMONG THE MOST COMMON HEALTH
CONDITIONS.
FACED BY CALIFORNIA CHILDREN.
MORE THE STUDY 5% A MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES.
DEVELOPMENT FOR A PERSON TURNS
TWENTY FIVE AND 79% OF YOUTH
WITH MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS DO NOT
ACCESS CARE.
THE BILL ESTABLISHES MIL HELP
DROP IN CENTERS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA ACCESSIBLE. TO ALL
YOUTH REGARDLESS OF THEIR
IMMIGRATION STATUS.
AND WHETHER OR NOT THEY ARE
INSURED.
THE MENTAL HEALTH -- OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION.
WOULD MINISTER TO GRANTS TO THE
COUNTY CITIES.
AND OR LOCAL ENTITIES ACROSS THE
STATE.
NOW YOU SHOULD NEVER FEEL LIKE
THEY DON'T HAVE A SAFE PLACE TO
GO WHEN THEY ARE FACING WITH
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES.
YOU NEED A SAFE HAVEN.
NO WRONG DOOR YOU FRIENDLY.
AND CULTURALLY COMPETENT.
PLACE WHERE THEY CAN ACCESS THE
CARE THEY NEED.
NOW SANTA CLARA COUNTY IS
CURRENTLY DEVELOPING TO YOUTH
DROP IN CENTER IS BASED ON THE
AUSTRALIAN MODEL THAT PROVIDES
WRAPAROUND CARE.
BY UTILIZING PEERS LICENSED
PROVIDERS AND COUNTY HEALTH
PROGRAMS.
SB TRIAL WOULD BRING THIS --
PROGRAM STATEWIDE.
THIS BILL IS A COMPANION BILL TO
THE NEXT BILL I WILL PRESENT.
WHICH IS SB.
FIVE EIGHTY TWO THAT CREATES A
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE COUNTIES
IN SCHOOLS. TO PROVIDE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ON CAMPUS.
COURSE SB TWELVE WILL PROVIDE.
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES OFF
CAMPUS.
TOGETHER THESE BILLS ENSURE THAT
ALL YOU CAN RECEIVE SERVICES AT
SCHOOL.
OR IN A SAFE NEIGHBORHOOD
LOCATION.
AND WE HAVE TWO WITNESSES.
TOBY YELLING AND MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES OVERSIGHT COMMISSION.
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AND PHOEBE'S
**** -- USE FROM ALCOHOL PROGRAM
SO JOURNAL TO MY WITNESSES.
MANAGER HELLO -- I'M PHOEBE ****
AND I'M A RISING SENIOR GOT HIGH
SCHOOL IN PALO ALTO -- FRESHMAN
YEAR I USED TO FALL ASLEEP
READING ARTICLES ABOUT WHAT
HILLS WOULD BE LEGAL.
OR WITH A KITCHEN KNIFE UNDER MY
PILLOW JUST IN CASE THINGS GOT
TOO HARD TO HANDLE.
IT FELT LIKE A SECURITY BLANKET
HAVING THE CONTROLLED END IT ALL.
AS A YOUNG PERSON AND AN ADULT
DOMINATED WORLD I AND MANY OF MY
PEERS FEEL LACK OF CONTROL OVER
ABUNDANCE OF FACTORS IN OUR
LIVES.
WHEN YOU DON'T HAVE MUCH FREEDOM
WHEN INDEPENDENCE AND ADULTHOOD
LOOMS AHEAD ASKING FOR HELP
FEELS LIKE A STEP BACKWARDS?
I'VE GROWN UP FORTUNATE SO WHEN
I STARTED FEELING DEPRESSED I
FEEL GUILTY LIKE I DIDN'T
DESERVE TO FEEL THE WAY THAT I
DID.
BUT THE LONGER I HELD IT IN
[inaudible]
THE MORE.
THE MORE A GOTTEN GOTTEN -- MY
GRADES STARTED TO SLIP SECOND
SEMESTER OF MY FRESHMAN YEAR.
AND SCHOOL STRESS ISOLATED ME
FROM REALITY.
THEN I STARTED GETTING
VALIDATION FROM A BOY TWO YEARS
OLDER THAN ME -- IN A WORLD
WHERE GRADES DISPLAYED WORTH I
FELT LIKE MORE THAN THAT TO HIM.
AND THIS IN SECURITY AND BLIND
TRUST ME TO BE IN A BATHROOM
WHERE I WAS SEXUALLY ASSAULTED.
BY THE TRUSTED PERSON I TRUSTED
THE MOST.
HE LEFT ME AND I FELT HUMILIATED
I FELT LIKE MY ONLY OPTIONS WERE
TO STRUGGLE THROUGH IT ALONE OR
KILL MYSELF.
BECAUSE REACHING OUT WOULD MEAN
SURRENDERING ANY FREEDOM THAT I
DID HAVE.
AFTER GETTING HOSPITALIZED IN
PROCESSING WHAT I'D BEEN THROUGH
WITH A NEW THERAPIST I HAD A
NEED TO CHANGE OUR SUPPORT
SYSTEM FOR YOU.
ALL CO HELPED ME FIND MY CONTROL
AGAIN.
IT GAVE ME HOPE THAT OTHER
ADOLESCENTS WHO FELT LIKE I FELT.
CAN GET HELP AND THAT SELF
AWARENESS AND REACHING OUT FOR
SUPPORT WOULD BE TREATED AS A
SIGN OF MATURITY AND STRENGTH AS
OPPOSED TO WEAKNESS.
I NEEDED A SPACE THAT WASN'T AT
SCHOOL A PLACE I COULD GO TO TO
BE VULNERABLE.
NOT FEEL LIKE A LIABILITY ISSUE
I DON'T KNOW WHETHER OR NOT I
WOULD HAVE GONE TO ALTHOUGH IF
IT WERE BEEN IT'D BEEN A
POSSIBILITY FOR ME.
BUT HAVING THAT SAFETY NET AND A
RESOURCE TO TURN TO BEFORE
RESORTING AND SUICIDE NEEDS TO
BE AN OPTION FOR OUR YOUTH.
THANK YOU.
MEDICARE MEMBERS TOBY OWING THEY
TAKE A DIRECT MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION I'D I
DON'T THINK I WAS PREPARED TO
SIT NEXT TO TV TODAY.
AND SO I WANT TO THANK HER FOR
COMING AND SHARING THAT STORY.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT -- FROM THE
COMMISSION'S PERSPECTIVE WE HEAR
FAR TOO OFTEN.
THAT YOUNG PEOPLE DON'T FIND THE
SERVICES THEY NEED DESIGNED IN A
WAY THAT IS APPROPRIATE FOR
THOSE NEEDS AND WHO THEY ARE.
IN THE COMMUNITY SYSTEM THAT WE
HAVE -- THE COMMISSION IS
SPONSORING THIS LEGISLATION
SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE IT IT
INTENDS -- TO CHANGE THE SYSTEM
BY STARTING WITH THE NEEDS OF
YOUNG PEOPLE.
AND MAKING FUNDS AVAILABLE IN A
STRATEGY AVAILABLE TO ENSURE
THAT OUR SYSTEM IS.
ASKING YOUNG PEOPLE WHAT THOSE
NEEDS ARE HOW TO DESIGN SERVICES
IN WAYS THAT ARE APPROPRIATE FOR
THOSE NEEDS.
AND THAT THAT THAT WE CAN
DELIVER A RANGE OF SERVICES THAT
ARE TAILORED TO THEIR INTEGRATED.
AND THAT HAVE THIS THE
TREMENDOUS POTENTIAL THAT WE'VE
SEEN IN OTHER COUNTRIES TO
RESULT IN THE KINDS OF OUTCOMES
WE NEED IN CALIFORNIA.
NAMELY THAT WE HELP PEOPLE WORK
THROUGH THE ISSUES THAT ARE
AFFECTING THEIR BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH.
THAT WE RECOGNIZE HOW IMPORTANT
IT IS FOR YOUNG PEOPLE TO
GRADUATE FROM HIGH SCHOOL TO
FIND THOSE SOCIAL SUPPORT IN
THOSE NETWORKS TO FIND
EMPLOYMENT.
AND BE SUCCESSFUL WE'RE VERY
EXCITED ABOUT THIS LEGISLATION
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
BUT I I HOPE YOU HEARD FROM THE
TESTIMONY -- THAT THIS IS A
REALITY FACING TOO MANY YOUNG
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA WE HOPE TO
CHANGE THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THERE OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON YVONNE COUNTRY --
WITH THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS
AND SUPPORT.
ERIC HARRIS WITH DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
CONNIE DELGADO ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
ROBERT HARRISON BE HAVE A
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF ADDICTION
MEDICINE AND SPORT.
NAME'S KEVIN CLARK ANABAPTISTS
ANNIKA FAMILY OF AGENCIES AMPLE
SUPPORT.
CHECK A FRAKER NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORK
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
DONNA ARE TO GIVE WHICH
CALIFORNIA STATE PTA IN SUPPORT.
NICOLE ORNAMENT ON BEHALF OF THE
ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT.
DANIELLE MAILLET CALIFORNIA
LINES OF CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES AND SUPPORT.
TITUS MISS A STEINBERG INSTITUTE
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
WARNER MET NORM MINETA
REPRESENTING ALL COVE IN SUPPORT.
CHAKER ANY -- REPRESENTING ALL
CURVE IN SUPPORT.
LA FIN REPRESENTING ALCOVE AND
FULL SUPPORT.
STEPHEN THAT'LL SIME STANFORD
DEPARTMENT OF PSYCHIATRY IN FULL
SUPPORT.
WEST ONLY AND WE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR YOUTH
IN SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL.
SEEING NONE ANY OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE MEMBERS
[inaudible]
THE COMMITTEE.
I DON'T SEE ANY QUESTIONS YEAH I
NEED A MOTION.
NO NO I'VE NEVER FOR ME HAVE
DONE GUN AT THAT TIME FORM GETS
IN THE WAY.
IF YOU DON'T MIND I'D LIKE TO
JUST MAKE A COMMENT.
PHOEBE THANK YOU FOR COMING
TODAY I KNOW IT'S NOT EASY TO
COME BUT IT MEANS A LOT TO THOSE
OF US ARE SITTING HERE.
AND PRIMARILY THAT I HAVE
STUDENTS COME IN MY OFFICE QUITE
A BIT.
AND I ALSO SOMETIMES ADVISORS TO
STEP OUT.
DOW SOMEHOW SCHOOL REALLY IS AND
WHAT'S GOING ON AND THEY ARE SO
HONEST AND THEY'RE SO SCARED AND
THEY HAVE -- SO MANY PLACES THAT
HAVE PLACES TO GO TALK TO
SOMEONE.
AND SO ON I WANT TO HONOR CENTER
YOUR BILL FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
BILL.
AND YOUR BRAVERY AND I SEE SOME
OF YOUR FRIENDS HERE TODAY AND
THAT THEY CAME UP AS WELL --
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR COMING
UP BECAUSE WE DO LISTEN TO YOU
AND SOMETIMES PEOPLE DON'T THINK
GOVERNMENT DOESN'T WORK BUT IT
DOES.
SO SENATOR BILL IF YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
MEMBERS I APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT -- ONE MOTION IS MY
THINKING.
YOUR ANOTHER BILLING WONDERS
NORTHERN AS WELL.
OKAY WELL WAIT UNTIL WE HAVE A
QUORUM AND LOG -- DO THE MOTION
AT THAT TIME.
OKAY WE'LL MOVE ON TO SB. FIVE
EIGHTY TWO FOR SENATOR BILL.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS -- SB FIVE
EIGHTY TWO IS THE SORT OF THE
SECOND HALF OF THE USE MENTAL
HEALTH EQUATION.
THIS BILL WILL BOLSTER MENTAL
HEALTH PARTNERSHIPS. TO MAKE
SURE.
SCHOOL OF CHILDREN RECEIVE HELP
AND SCHOOL SETTINGS -- 50% OF
ALL LIKE TIME CASES OF MENTAL
HEALTH BEGIN BY AGE FOURTEEN
AGAIN.
SO AT LEAST 50% OF OUR TENSION A
RESOURCES.
PROBABLY SHOULD BE FOCUSED ON
YOU.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
GIVING SCHOOLS.
THE RESOURCES THEY NEED.
SO THAT YOUTH AND SCHOOL
SETTINGS HAVE MENTAL HEALTH
SUPPORT.
ALSO I MIGHT ADD THE TEACHERS
SHOULD HAVE.
SUB SUPPORT.
IF YOU EVER HEARD FROM TEACHERS.
THAT TEACH TEACH IN CLASSROOMS
WITH MAYBE ONE OR EVEN TWO
STUDENTS WITH A BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH PROBLEM.
IT WILL DISRUPT THE WHOLE CLASS.
SO THEY NEED SUPPORT.
TO AND WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
OUR SCHOOLS -- HAVE THE
RESOURCES THAT THEY NEED SO
YOUTH IN SCHOOL SETTINGS HAVE
THAT SUPPORT.
THIS MENTAL HELP TRIAGE FRONTS
ARE INTENDED TO HAVE A FOCUS ON
YOUTH AND CHILDREN BUT THE
MAJORITY THE FUNDS HAVE BEEN USE
ACTUALLY FOR ADULTS NOT CHILDREN.
IT'S KIND OF INTERESTING.
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AND
OVERSIGHT ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION HAS BEEN WORKING. TO
CORRECT THIS INDIRECT -- MORE OF
THESE GRANTS TO PROGRAMS THAT
SERVE YOU.
SB.
FIVE EIGHTY TWO REQUIRES THAT
50% OF THE BILL HELP TRIAGE
FUNDS BE ALLOCATED TO THE YOUTH
PROGRAMS.
THE FUNDING INCENTIVIZE IS
COUNTIES AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
PARTNER.
AND INTEGRATE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES IN THE SCHOOLS.
AND WE EXPECT THE POOL OF
APPLICANTS TO SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE GIVEN THE SIGNIFICANT
NEED AN INTEREST IN A GREAT.
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES IN THE
SCHOOLS.
NOW FOR EXAMPLE OF ONE OF THE
CORE DEMANDS.
RECENTLY.
IN LOS ANGELES.
WHAT TEACHERS WERE THEY WERE ON
STRIKE AND THEY WANTED TO
PROVIDE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
ON SCHOOL SITES?
WHAT THEY CALL COMMUNITIES BASED
SCHOOL SO THEY HAD A?
THEY SAID WELL WE'RE HAVING
OVERCROWDED CLASSROOMS WE NEED
HELP.
IN THE CLASSROOM WE LIKE TO HAVE.
SOME SUPPORT. FOR US TEACHERS.
IN THE CLASSROOM AND WE THINK
ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
IS TO HAVE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PROGRAMS. TO HELP US DO A BETTER
JOB TEACHING.
THE BILL ENJOYS SUPPORT OF THE
MAIL HELP PROVIDERS AS LONG AS
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS AND ALL TURN OVER
TO OUR WITNESSES AND TURN OVER
WITNESSES THAT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON YVONNE COUNTRY
WITH THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS.
AT THIS COMMITTEE IT IS WELL
AWARE -- OUR THIRD WE'RE FACING
HISTORIC RATES IN TERMS OF
STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH -- MY
COLLEAGUES AND I CAN'T GO
ANYWHERE -- IN THE STATE WITHOUT
HEARING GUT WRENCHING STORIES OF
RELATED TO ANXIETY DEPRESSION.
TRAUMA SUICIDE IDEATION.
I'LL JUST QUICKLY SHARE A FEW OF
THE STORIES SOME OF THEM ARE
RELATED TO ANXIETY LEVELS
REACHING THE POINT OF TEMPORARY
PARALYSIS.
SOME OF THEM ARE RELATED TO TO
STUDENTS ATTEMPTING TO COPE WITH
THE LOSS OF FRIENDS AND WILD
FIRES.
AND FAR TOO MANY OF THEM
TRAGICALLY ARE ARE RELATED TO
YOUNG CHILDREN -- COMMITTING
SUICIDE -- IN IN WHAT'S BECOME
VERY CLEAR IT SET SET TO US AS
AN ASSOCIATION IS THAT THESE ARE
NOT HAPPENING IN ISOLATION --
WITH THE THEY'RE NOT EXCEPTIONS
TO THE RULE -- THE THE THESE ARE
BECOMING THE NORM UNFORTUNATELY.
I MEAN WE REALLY BELIEVE THAT
SCHOOLS ARE IN A PRIME POSITION
TO TO HELP MEET THE NEEDS.
OF OF STUDENTS TO MENTAL HEALTH
NEEDS OF STUDENTS.
ON WALL EDUCATORS ARE WELL
INTENTIONED -- STUDENTS NEED
DIRECT ACCESS TO MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS -- IN THIS BILL
WILL WILL HELP ACHIEVE THAT --
WE WE BELIEVE THAT.
THE HIGHER PRIORITIZATION OF THE
USE OF THE FUNDS WILL BE TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS IN SCHOOLS.
THE NUMBER THE AMOUNT OF TIME
THAT STUDENTS SPEND ON CAMPUS
ALLOWS MENTAL PROBLEM HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS DEVELOP WITH THE
TRUSTING RELATIONSHIPS -- WITH
WITH KIDS -- BUT ALSO IT IT'S
ABOUT ACCESSIBILITY.
AND FAR TOO OFTEN COMMUNITY
BASED SERVICES AREN'T ACCESSIBLE
PARTICULARLY IN RURAL AND REMOTE
AREAS -- WITHIN YOUR SERVICE A
PROVIDER MAY BE A THIRTY MINUTE
DRIVE AWAY -- SO WE WE WERE
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB FIVE EIGHT
TWO AND AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR IDOL.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
AGAIN TOBY OWING WITH THE MENTAL
HEALTH COMMISSION.
AS A MY COLLEAGUES STATED IS YOU
KNOW WE SPEND A LOT OF TIME
TRAVELING AS WELL TALKING WITH
ADMINISTRATORS -- IN SCHOOLS
TALKING COUNTY EVER HEALTH
DIRECTORS TALKING WITH PARENTS
YOUTH AND SCHOOL MENTAL HEALTH
HAS BECOME THE FACE OF THE
MENTAL HEALTH CHALLENGE IN
CALIFORNIA FOR YOUNG PEOPLE. FOR
OLDER FO IT FOR ADULTS IT'S
HOMELESSNESS AND CRIMINAL
JUSTICE INVOLVEMENT BUT FOR
CHILDREN AND YOUTH IT'S THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE'RE SEEING IN
THE SCHOOL SITES IN TERMS OF
EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES.
MEN HOUSE SERVICES ACT
EXPLICITLY IDENTIFIES SUPPORTING
THE ABILITY OF YOUNG PEOPLE TO
THE STATE IN SCHOOL.
AS A BEHAVIORAL HEALTH GOAL.
THE COMMISSION HAS DONE A NUMBER
OF THINGS AS SENATOR BILL POINTS
OUT TO A LINE THE DOLLARS THAT
ARE CURRENTLY AVAILABLE WITH
THIS GOAL WHAT SB FIVE EIGHTY
TWO IS IS PUTS THAT IN STATUTE
PROVIDES SOME ADDITIONAL
FLEXIBILITY. TO USE THESE FUNDS
IN WAYS THAT ARE MORE TAILORED
TO THE LOCAL NEEDS.
AND IT REALLY CREATE SOME
INCENTIVES TO STRENGTHEN THE
OPPORTUNITIES BETWEEN COUNTIES
AND SCHOOLS THAT WE CAN DELIVER
CARE IN WAYS THAT ARE VERY
MEANINGFUL FOR YOUNG PEOPLE.
IT IS AS THE SENATOR SAID IN
SOME WAYS A COMPANION TO THE
OTHER BILL TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE SERVICES AVAILABLE IN THE
COMMUNITY AS WELL AS ON CAMPUSES.
SO THAT WE CAN SUPPORT OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE WERE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
THIS BILL HAS FROM THE AFTER I
VOTE AND HAVE BEEN ANSWERING
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THE
OTHERS IN SUPPORT -- CARES WITH
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
ROBERT HARRIS ON THE HAVE IN
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY VERDICTS IN
MEDICINE ONE OF THE VERY
EARLIEST ENDORSERS OF PROP SIXTY
THREE AND WHAT'S FUNNY AND IT'S
ABOUT TIME AND SEND TO BELL'S
BEEN WORKING ON THIS FOR EVER SO
THANK YOU.
PROSECUTORS HERE ON BEHALF OF
CHILD AND ADOLESCENT --
PSYCHIATRY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
DANNY OFFER FROM PLATEN ADVISORS
REPRESENTING THE NATIONAL
ALLIANCE ON MENTAL ILLNESS NAMI
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT THANK.
WARNER REPRESENTING ALL COVE IN
SUPPORT.
J. CRANIA REPRESENTING ALL CURVE
IN SUPPORT.
ELEPHANT REPRESENTING ALL CURVE
AND FULL SUPPORT.
PHOEBE **** REPRESENTING ALL
COVE IN FULL SUPPORT.
I'M A LILY SO DONE WITH THE
STANFORD CENTER FOR YOUTH MENTAL
HEALTH AND ELL BEING AND I'LL
CURVE AND WE'RE IN SUPPORT.
STEVE THAT'LL TIME STANFORD
PSYCHIATRY DEPARTMENT CENTER FOR
YOUTH MENTAL HEALTH AND WELL
BEING IN SUPPORT.
HELEN ROTH THOUSAND TEACHERS FOR
HEALTHY KIDS IN FULL SUPPORT.
DANIELLE MAILLET CALIFORNIA LAND
TO CHILD AND FAMILY SERVICES IN
SUPPORT.
ALYSSA MCGUIRE WITH TWENTIETH
VOICES STRONGLY SUPPORT.
ANGEL CORTEZ -- WITH SALONI
VOICES.
I STRONGLY SUPPORT.
BACK MANSON WAS LANI VOICES
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
SPENCER LANE NINETEEN WAS LONELY
VOICES I'VE BEEN IN AND OUT OF
THE MENTAL HEALTH CARE SYSTEM.
PLENTY OF TIMES [inaudible]
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
KIMBERLY FRANCO'S WITH FLY YOU
FROM PLACES I STRONGLY SUPPORT.
ALEXANDER HEATH WAS SOLANO YOUTH
VOICES I BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL
WILL BE GREATLY BENEFICIAL FOR
USE AS STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CONNIE DELGADO ON BEHALF
OF THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA HERE WITH THE SUPPORT
OF AMEND POSITION.
THE DIRECTORS RECENTLY TOOK THIS
POSITION WE HAD A CONVERSATION
WITH THE AUTHOR STAFF AND WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUE THIS CONVERSATION.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHERS
IN SUPPORT SEEING NONE ARE THERE
ANY IN OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL.
SEEING NONE OTHER ANY QUESTIONS
FROM THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
OKAY -- WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
YES -- HERO HEALTH IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT ELEMENT IN.
IN US STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT.
WE ALL AGREE WITHOUT IF SO.
THIS IS THE FIRST EFFORT.
WE'VE MADE AND MANY YEARS. TO
ACTUALLY INTEGRATE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH AND EDUCATION TOGETHER TO
ACHIEVE.
THOSE NEEDED GOALS OF OF A
STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT.
A BETTER LIFE I REGION I VOTE ON
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR AND
WILL WE FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS
SO WE HAVE A QUORUM --
APPRECIATE ALL OF YOU THE
TESTIFIED TODAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
OKAY ON NEXT IS -- SP
[inaudible]
FOUR FOUR FIVE CENTER PORTANTINO.
GOOD AFTERNOON SENATORS GOOD
AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON -- MADAM CHAIR
AND COLLEAGUES -- PRESENTING SP.
FOUR FOUR FIVE WHICH I BELIEVE
GOT OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE
UNANIMOUSLY LAST YEAR AND
UNANIMOUSLY EIGHTY DOES YOUR OFF
THE FLOOR -- MORE BACK AGAIN SB
FOUR FOUR FIVE REQUIRES.
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES TO CONVENE AN EXPERT
PANEL TO ADVISE -- DH CS ON THE
DEVELOPMENTAL DEVELOPMENT OF A
YOUTH SUBSTANCE THIS ORDER
TREATMENT STANDARDS.
THE BILL.
YOU KNOW THANK YOU GOOD.
YES.
ABSOLUTELY -- THE BILL DEFINES --
YOUTH -- S. U. D. TREATMENT
SERVICES TO INCLUDE ANY PUBLICLY
FUNDED DIRECT SERVICES INTENDED
TO ADDRESS OR TO TREAT AS YOU
DIS -- FOR INDIVIDUALS FROM
BIRTH TO TWENTY SIX YEARS OF AGE
CALIFORNIA'S MADE NUMEROUS
ATTEMPTS TO ADDRESS THE COMPLEX
NOT OF ISSUES RELATED TO MENTAL
HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE ABUSE.
AND THE OUR SYSTEM AND PROGRAMS
DON'T SEEM TO ALWAYS CARRY OUT
OUR INTENTIONS -- WE SEE THE
RESULTS AROUND US ON THE STREETS
AND OUR SCHOOLS AND IN CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
MULTIPLE STUDIES HAVE
ESTABLISHED THAT ADOLESCENTS ARE
MORE VULNERABLE THAN ADULTS TO
ALCOHOL CANNABIS TOBACCO AND
OTHER DRUG RELATED PROBLEMS.
SERVICES FOR YOUTH NEED TO BE
INTEGRATED AND WRAP AROUND --
AND ARE NECESSARY TO SERVE THE
YOUTH MOST IN NEED WHEREVER THEY
ARE IN THE COMMUNITY.
I WHETHER IT'S ON THE STREETS IN
A HOMELESS SHELTER OR IN A
FOSTER CARE OR GROUP HOME OR IN
SCHOOLS.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO ADDRESS ALL
OF THESE ISSUES THROUGH THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THIS YOU
TREATMENT STANDARD FOR CHILDREN
ADOLESCENTS AND YOUNG ADULTS BY
SPECIFICALLY ADDRESSING THEIR
NEEDS.
AS DIFFERENT AND THIS DISTINCT
FROM ADULTS -- BY DEVELOPING A
NEW METHODOLOGY FOR CARING FOR
OUR YOUNGER POPULOUS POPULATION
WITH ME TODAY HAVE DR -- TìM
SIR MACK -- FORMER PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF
ADDICTION MEDICINE AND VOTED I
SAY THAT RIGHT I HOPE.
I WAS I CLOSE.
WHY?
WHY VOTE A SANTA CLARA COUNTY --
PSYCHIATRIST AND THERAPIST AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I BUT WHEN
YOU HAVE A CORPSMAN CAN VOTE.
WELCOME DOCTOR SEARCH SERMON.
WELCOME.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TO TESTIFY HERE
I'VE BEEN WORKING ON TRYING TO
CREATE A SYSTEM.
INTEGRATED SYSTEM FOR A
TREATMENT OF ADOLESCENTS
SUBSTANCE USE.
SINCE -- TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN
WHEN I WROTE TO YOU FIRST --
FOUR THE CAL FOR CALIFORNIA
SOCIETY OF ADDICTION MEDICINE I
WAS I CHAIRED THE YOUTH WORK
GROUP FOR THE BLUE RIBBON
COMMISSION.
ON MARIJUANA POLICY AND IS AND
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR NEWSOME AND
I HAVE -- I'M THE AUTHOR OF THE
MODEL SET OF STANDARDS FOR A
USED TREATMENT -- FOR THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF ADDICTION
MEDICINE I BROUGHT COPIES -- FOR
FOR THE MEMBERS HERE -- THIS IS
WHAT STANDARDS COMES DOWN.
TO WE NEED A INTEGRATED
CONTINUUM OF CARE A SYSTEM OF
CARE.
IF WE DON'T HAVE STANDARDS THEN
THE PROGRAMS THAT GET FUNDED
WILL BE PROGRAMS WHICH ARE --
BROUGHT TO US BY -- PRIVATE --
TREATMENT CENTERS BY PREVENTION
ENTREPRENEURS BY DIFFERENT --
GOVERNMENTAL AGENCIES AND WE
WILL END UP WITH A COLLECTION A
A FRAGMENTED COLLECTION OF
SERVICES FOR YOUTH.
WE NEED TO TAKE THE MONEY THAT'S
AVAILABLE THROUGH PROP SIXTY
FOUR AND YES PDT AND MENTAL
HEALTH.
ARE COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH AND
CREATE AN INTEGRATED SYSTEM THAT
STARTS IN THE SCHOOLS.
WHO IS -- STUDENT ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE STANDARDS
PROGRAMMATIC STANDARDS AND
STANDARDS FOR OF THE SPECIALTY
TRAINING OF THE COUNSELORS.
WITH THAT'S WITH THE
PRETREATMENT HAPPENS THAT'S
WHERE THE EDUCATION THE
PREVENTION AND THE AND THE EARLY
INTERVENTION HAPPENS AND THEN WE
NEED VERY CLOSE LIAISON WITH
COMMUNITY BASED CENTRES.
WHICH WILL DO THE ACTUAL
TREATMENT THE EVALUATION TO SEE
IF TREATMENTS NEEDED THE
INTENSIVE OUTPATIENT TREATMENT
THE ON GOING OUT PATIENT
TREATMENT -- AND ESOS COMMUNITY
CENTERS IT SHOULD HAVE SPECIAL
LEAVE OUT REACH FOR SCHOOL
DROPOUTS FOR TREATMENT DROP OUTS
FOR HOMELESS YOUTH.
WE NEED TO RECOGNIZE THAT A
SYSTEM OF TREATMENT FOR
ADOLESCENTS HAS TO BE SEPARATE
AND DIFFERENT FROM ANY TREATMENT
FOR FOR ADULTS WHY DOES IT HAVE
TO BE DIFFERENT. FOR SAFETY
PURPOSES -- IT PEOPLE EARLY IN
ABSENCE WHO ARE FOURTEEN YEARS
OLD AND IT CAN'T BE PUT TOGETHER
WITH PEOPLE OR TWENTY TWO YEARS
OLD WHO WERE -- EARLY IN ABSENCE
THEY DON'T HAVE THE BEST
BOUNDARIES SAFETY IS ONE MAJOR
REASON WE NEED TO HAVE -- IT
SEPARATE BECAUSE THE THE
TREATMENT GOALS ARE DIFFERENT
FOR USE YOUTH ARE.
A LOT OF TIMES WHEN YOU'RE
TWENTY TWO TO THE TREATMENT GOAL
IS TO LAUNCH FROM YOUR FAMILY
WHEREAS WHEN YOU'RE FOURTEEN
IT'S TO RECOGNIZE YOUR
DEPENDENCE UPON THAT FAMILY.
WE HAVE TO HAVE MUCH MORE
INTENSE FAMILY AND FROM OF
TREATMENT IN ADOLESCENCE CENTERS
BECAUSE A LOT OF THESE -- USE
ARE IN FAMILIES WERE TRYING WAS
NOT IN THE PAST IS HAPPENING
CURRENTLY WE NEED HIGHLY
SPECIALIZED TRAINING THAT YOU
DON'T NEED TO HAVE IN ADOLESCENT.
TO OUR I MEAN INTO DON'T
TREATMENT BECAUSE YOU NEED TO BE
SENSITIVE TO ALL OF THE
PSYCHOLOGICAL DEVELOPMENT IS
HAPPENING IN ADOLESCENCE.
I BELIEVE WE HAVE AN OBLIGATION
WE HAVE A AN INDUSTRY RIGHT NOW
WHICH IS LEGAL WHICH IS SELLING
MARIJUANA.
THAT INDUSTRY SHOULD BE
OBLIGATED TO HELP PICK UP THE
COST OF REMEDIATION FOR ANY
DAMAGE DONE BY THEIR PRODUCT.
AND THAT MEANS PROP SIXTY FOUR
FUNDS ALONG WITH THE OTHER FUNDS
NEED TO BE SIR OF NEED TO BE --
UNDER RATING PROGRAMS WHICH BY
STANDARDS HAVE TO BE INTEGRATED
INTO AN ON CONTINUUM OF CARE
FROM SCHOOLS. TO THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY BASED TREATMENT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HI -- I AM AS WELL VOTE I AM A
LICENSED CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKER
WITH COUNTY OF SANTA CLARA
[inaudible]
AND I'M ALSO PROUD MEMBER OF
SEIU.
LOCAL FIVE TWENTY ONE I'M HERE
REPRESENTING THOUSAND OF MEMBERS
OF HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONALS --
ABOUT COMMUNITY MEMBERS AND ALSO
OUR CLIENTS.
AND TO TOUCH BASE -- JUST TO
FOLLOW UP ON WHAT TIM HAS SAID.
I BEEN A LICENSED CLINICIAN AND
HAVE WORKED IN THIS -- FEEL
PROVIDING MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT -- FOR CHILDREN
ADOLESCENTS AGE SIX THROUGH THE
AGE OF EIGHTEEN US IN THE YEAR
TWO THOUSAND AND FIVE AND BEFORE
PRIOR MY CURRENT POSITION I HAD
WORK WITH INCARCERATED YOUTH AND
YOUTH WHO WERE INVOLVING
CHILDREN OPERATION SYSTEM -- WHO
WERE HIGHLY IMPACTED BY
COMMUNITY VIOLENCE -- FORM AND
SUBSTANCE ABUSE.
AND OF FROM MY TRAINING.
I KNOW THAT BOTH BEHAVIOR HEALTH
AND SUBSTANCE ABUSE CHALLENGES
SHARE A COMMON THREAT.
WHICH IS TRAUMA -- A LOT OF
UNRESOLVED EARLY CHILDHOOD
TRAUMA [inaudible]
AND IN ORDER. TO FORM EFFECTIVE
TRAUMA INFORMED CARE -- FOR THE
YOUTH POPULATION IT ALL BEGINS
WITH EXTENSIVE TRAUMA TRAINING
FOR OUR CLINICIANS FOR OUR
DIRECT CARE PROVIDERS -- SO THEY
CAN ACTIVELY LOOK AT MENTAL
HEALTH CHALLENGE IT'S UP TO YOU
CHALLENGE FROM A TRAUMA INFORMED
LEADS.
AND BY THAT I MEAN -- FOR MY
WORK WITH INCARCERATED YOUTH I
LOOK.
AT THESE YOUTH AND THEIR
CHALLENGES COMING FROM A PLACE
OF EXTREME SUFFERINGS.
PAIN AND A LOT OF WOUNDING THAT
BEGAN IN THEIR EARLY.
IN THEIR FAMILY OF ORIGIN -- AND
THAT LET THEM TO SEEK SAFETY AND
A SENSE OF BELONGING.
IN DIFFERENT ALTERNATIVE COPING
MECHANISM ELSEWHERE IN SUBSTANCE
ABUSE IS ONE WAY T COPE.
WITH THE UNRESOLVED PROBLEM --
SO IN ORDER TO FORM -- GOING
BACK.
TO IN ORDER TO FORM A BETTER
SYSTEM OF COMMON FORM CARE I WAS
I WOULD ENCOURAGE.
THAT WE A SUPPORT SB FOUR FOUR
FIVE TO RAISE THE BAR AND AIM
FOR EXCELLENCE IN FORMING FORM
OF TREATMENT PROGRAMS FOR THESE
YOUTH SO THAT THEIR DON'T SYSTEM
WILL NOT BE IMPACTED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER OTHERS
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR BRAIN IN
MARCH YOU WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION ALSO SUPPORT.
TOM RENT FREE WITH THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
SHERRI DAILY WITH CALIFORNIA
CONSORTIUM OF ADDICTION PROGRAMS
AND PROFESSIONALS IN SUPPORT.
BETSY ARMSTRONG ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS IN SUPPORT.
KELLY BROOKS ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION HERE IN SUPPORT.
ON SHEET SO ON BEHALF OF ST
JOHN'S WERE CHILD FAMILY CENTER
CUT COSTS BUT CO SPONSOR OF THE
BILL AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THURMOND DATING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN SUPPORT.
DANIEL A CALIFORNIA LINES OF
CHILD AND FAMILY SERVICES AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HARDING THANK YOU
SENATE ARE AT AS YOU SAID THIS
WAS BEFORE US LAST YEAR AND IT
PASSED UNANIMOUSLY.
AND I I SUPPORT GAIN THIS YEAR
BUT BUT ONE THE ISSUES THAT CAME
UP LAST YEAR AT I KNOW YOU HAD
SOME.
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE EDUCATION
GROUPS AS FAR AS THE FUNDING
ISSUE I JUST WANT TO KNOW IF YOU
COULD GO ON RECORD IN IN THAT IS
ESSENTIALLY FOR THOSE OF YOU
DON'T REMEMBER THIS AND YOUR
WITNESS MENTIONED EARLIER THAT.
AND IDEA TO FUND THIS WHEN THE
PLANT COMES ABOUT TALKING ABOUT --
ADEQUATE IN NEEDED TREATMENT.
FOR SUBSTANCE ABUSE FOR OUR
YOUTH IS IS PROP SIXTY FOUR AND
YOU KNOW THAT.
IT'S KIND OF LIKE THE CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM IS A MILLION IDEAS.
AND NOT ENOUGH MONEY.
AND AND YOU KNOW THE ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I'VE BEEN BRINGING
UP IS IN THE INITIATIVE.
YOU KNOW THEY TALKED ABOUT TO
THE VOTERS WHAT THEY WANT TO
FOCUS ON IT WAS AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS AND YOU KNOW THAT THERE
ARE OTHER IDEAS INCLUDING THIS
ONE SO.
IT WHAT WHAT'S YOUR NOTION OF
THE OF THE AND FUNDING STREAM
FOR FOR THESE EFFORTS.
LIKE ALL GOOD POLICY MAKERS I
WANT TO SET UP THE FRAMEWORK
FIRST -- WE HAVE NOT LOOKED AT
ALL THE INTRICATE FUNDING --
THAT'S AVAILABLEAND I'M OPEN TO
HAVING THAT CONVERSATION WITH
YOU WHICH I THINK WAS THE ANSWER
I GAVE YOU LAST YEAR'S WELCOME.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
THE COMMITTEE.
BEFORE YOU GO ON WE'D LIKE TO
TAKE A ROLL CALL AND SO WE CAN
MAKE SURE WE CAN GET A YOUR VOTE
[inaudible]
SECRETARY [inaudible]
WHAT [inaudible]
MAYES AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
BIGELOW.
THE LEFT BONTA.
BURKE.
CARRILLO FLORA.
LIMON.
MCCARTY HERE IN THIS AREA.
RAMOS RODRIGUEZ.
SANTIAGO.
WALDRON.
YEAH ONE MORE WALKING AND THE
CHAIR.
IT WOULD AND AND RISK AREA.
LOOKING.
FOR MORE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR -- SO VERY HAD
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
AND WE HAVE A QUORUM.
OKAY HERE YOU'RE AWESOME -- THE
MOTION WAS BY.
THIS WHOLE THING WAS WATER MADE
THE MOTION TO MENTION WHO MADE
THE SECOND.
JULY SECOND AT BURKE THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR WE COULDN'T DO
THIS WITHOUT YOU.
I'M HAPPY TO HELP.
ALL RIGHT SO WE GET THAT SQUARED
AWAY -- THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
EDUCATION -- MADAM SECRETARY.
PART OF NO HE SAID DID YOU WANNA
CLOSE. FOR YES FOR AND I'LL GET.
BETTER YEAH SO ANYWAY -- OF WELL
IT'S NOT.
WHERE IS IT TOO BUT WE'RE TO DO
PASSING [inaudible]
TO THE EDUCATION RIGHT.
HEY ON WHERE.
WE'RE REALLY CONFUSED NOW I'M
SORRY.
A WRONG BROUGH.
WELL THEY HAVE [inaudible]
FORTY WE HAVE.
YEAH THIS ONE SAYS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS OKAY.
BETTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL WHAT I WOULD AYE MAYES.
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY I
BIGELOW.
BONTA.
BONTA AYE BURKE BURKE I CARILLO
CARILLO AYE FLORA FLORA ALONE.
CARTY.
MCCARTY AYE NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE ROMMEL'S RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
WALTER.
WALDRON AYE MAYES MAYES AYE
[inaudible]
LEVELS ARE.
AFTER ALL THAT YOUR BILL IS OUT
ON A VOTE OF ELEVEN ZERO WILL BE
THE ROLE OF OPEN FOR OTHERS TO
ADD ON THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MISTER MISTER PORTANTINO.
SO WITH THE OTHER.
2% [inaudible]
AT THE OKAY [inaudible]
OKAY.
SENATOR BATES WHENEVER
.
SO CENTER BASE YOU HAVE US
SENATE BILL.
FIVE EIGHTY NINE THANK YOU AND
GOOD AFTERNOON AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO
START BY ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENT AND THANK ALL YOUR
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH MY STAFF.
OF FOUR ON THE AMENDMENT.
THE BILL PROHIBITS AN OPERATOR
OF THE FOLLOWING TYPES OF
FACILITIES FROM PROVIDING ANY
FORM OF FALSE ADVERTISING OR
MARKETING SERVICES THE LICENSE
RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT FACILITY.
A CERTIFIED ALCOHOL OR OTHER
DRUG PROGRAM RECOVERY RESIDENTS
OR ANOTHER THIRD PARTY OVER THE
PAST YEAR ARE LEGISLATURE HAS
RECOGNIZED THAT CONSUMERS WAS
SUBSTANCE.
USE DISORDERS HAVE DISABLING
CONDITIONS AND THAT THESE
CONSUMERS AND THEIR FAMILIES
HAVE BEEN VERY VULNERABLE.
HOWEVER THERE ARE NO PROVISIONS
IN CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND SAFETY
CODE TO CONTROL UNETHICAL
MARKETING PRACTICES THAT PREY ON
DISTRESSED FAMILIES OR
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE IN.
CRISIS SEEKING TREATMENT AS A
RESULT OF PATIENTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES HAVE BEEN MISLED.
MISDIRECTED IN MISDIAGNOSED BY
AND QUALIFIED INDIVIDUALS THE
GOAL OF SB FIVE EIGHT NINE IS TO
PROTECT INDIVIDUALS WITH
ADDICTION.
PRINT BEING TREATED ADVERSELY
AND ENSURE THAT THEY ARE
RECEIVING THE TREATMENT THAT
THEY HAVE BEEN PROMISED
MARKETEERS WHO KNOWINGLY AND
WILLFULLY MAKE MATERIALLY FALSE
STATEMENTS.
WHETHER IN ADVERTISING OR BY
DIRECT COMMUNICATION WITH
CURRENT OR POTENTIAL PATIENTS
SHOULD BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
ARE THE BILL AWFUL ARE ALSO
AUTHORIZES DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES TO INVESTIGATE
ALLEGATIONS OF MISCONDUCT.
IN IMPOSE SANCTIONS ULTIMATELY
THE MEASURE SEEKS TO PROTECT
THOSE WHO ARE AT THEIR MOST
VULNERABLE SEEKING TREATMENT.
THE BILL IS SUPPORTED BY A
NUMBER.
OF ORGANIZATIONS CALIFORNIA
CONSORTIUM OF ADDICTION PROGRAMS
AND PROFESSIONALS AND WITH ME
TODAY FROM THAT ORGANIZATION IS
SHERRY DAILY.
HI WHO WILL PROVIDE SOME
CLARIFICATION ON THE BILL AND
ITS PURPOSE.
I WILL CHAIR MEMBER SURE DAILY
WITH CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM OF
ADDICTION PROGRAMS AND
PROFESSIONALS I GUESS THE BEST
WAY TO EXPLAIN WHAT THE BILL
DOES IS TO GIVE A PRACTICAL
EXAMPLE SO A COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO
I PRETENDED TO BE A LOVED ONE
LOOKING FOR CARE. FOR MY
FICTIONAL DAUGHTER WHO AND
FICTIONAL OPIOID PROBLEM I
GOOGLED LIKE MOST PEOPLE DO WHEN
THEY'RE LOOKING FOR TREATMENT
ADDICTION TREATMENT AND MERCED
CALIFORNIA.
WHAT I GOT WAS A LONG LIST ON
ALL GOOGLE SEARCHES AS IS USUAL
I'VE NOR THE ADS AT THE TOP OF
THE PAGE AND I PICKED THE ONE
THAT HAD A PICTURE OF A
TREATMENT CENTER THAT I WAS
FAMILIAR WITH?
A CENTRAL VALLEY RECOVERY
SERVICES BEEN IN THE COMMUNITY
FOR MORE THAN TWENTY YEARS FELT
FAMILIAR WITH IT CLICK ON THAT
PICTURE AND IT TOOK ME TO A NEW
PAGE.
I'M NOT PAGE IT LISTED FOR FIVE
PLACES IN MERCED THAT I COULD
CHOOSE FROM.
AND HAD LITTLE MORE INFORMATION
NEXT TO THEIR PICTURES SO I
PICKED THE ONE CENTRAL VALLEY
RECOVERY SERVICES THAT I KNEW
ABOUT.
IT OPENED A NEW PAGE IT SHOWED
THE OUTSIDE OF THE FACILITY A
PICTURE OF THE DIRECTOR SOME OF
THE STAFF ALL OF THE AMENITIES
WHAT SERVICES WERE OFFERED WHAT.
INSURANCE THEY TOOK WHAT
NATIONAL CERTIFICATIONS.
THE PROGRAM HAD CURRENTLY HELD
AND ACROSS THE TOP OF THE PAGE.
THE NUMBERS WAS ANEIGHT HUNDRED
NUMBER TO CALL FOR HELP AND ON
THE SIDE.
WAS AN INFORMATION FORM TO
SUBMIT MY INFORMATION FOR
IMMEDIATE CONFIDENTIAL CALL BACK.
SO I FOLLOW THE REBEL HOME
CALLED THE EIGHT HUNDRED NUMBER.
THE PERSON IN JASON ANSWERED THE
PHONE AND ASKED IF I HAD A LOVED
ONE WHO HAD AN ADDICTION PROBLEM
AND I SAID YES.
ALL HE WANTED NOW WAS OR GENDER
HER AGE.
DRUG OF CHOICE IN MY INSURANCE I
GAVE THAT INFORMATION I THINK I
MENTIONED.
AN INSURANCE COMPANY WITH BLUE
AND THAT HE WAS QUITE EXCITED HE
PROCEEDED TO TELL ME THAT THERE
WASN'T ANY ROOM IN MERCED.
THAT HE COULD GET ME TO A
TREATMENT PROGRAM AND EITHER
FLORIDA SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA I
BELIEVE ORANGE COUNTY --
MICHIGAN HE THEN OFFERED A FREE
PLANE TICKET TO TAKE MY DAUGHTER
THERE HE DIDN'T ONCE ASK WHAT
HER CONDITION WAS WHAT SHE SAFE.
HAD SHE SEEN A DOCTOR WISH YOU
IMMEDIATE DANGER.
AND I SAID WELL WE'RE JUST
TALKING ABOUT RIGHT NOW HE
CONTINUED WITH THE HIGH PRESSURE
PRESSURE SALES ROUTINE TO TELL
ME THAT IF I DIDN'T HAVE MY
DAUGHTER INTO TREATMENT.
BY THE END OF THE WEEK AND SHE
WOULD DIE.
SO THIS IS HAPPENING EVERY DAY
THE DEPARTMENT NEEDS THE TOOLS.
TO GO AFTER THESE PATIENT
BROKERS WHO ARE SUFFICIENT
PEOPLE AND SCAMMING PEOPLE ON
THE INNER AND OUTER DRIVE THAT.
THANK YOU SINCERELY SHIP.
THANK YOU.
OTHER SENSE OF THANK YOU MISTER
MEMBERS TOM RENT FREE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
NICOLE ORNAMENT ON BEHALF OF THE
ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
IS THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
SEE KNOWN TO BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
AS YOU MOVE THE BILL.
I THOUGHT YOU SAID YOU MOVED TO
CONTACT.
YOUR SECOND.
TWO YEAH HE DID OKAY I'M SORRY --
THE CENTER BATES WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE.
I JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK DR THANK
YOU ALL.
FOR US ALL WORKING TOGETHER TO
MOVE SOME OF THE CERTAINLY
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION FORWARD TO
PROTECT HE'S VERY VULNERABLE
INDIVIDUALS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BRINGING
THE BILL FORWARD IT DOESN'T TRY
TO DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
THE MOTION BY MISTER AGUILAR
CURRY -- WE HAVE A SECOND BY
MISTER NAZARIAN.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS AND MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WHAT I WOULD AYE MAYES MAYES I
AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
I BIGELOW.
BONTA AYE BONTA AYE BURKE.
BURKE I CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE FLORA FLORA AYE LOW
MOAN.
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE RAMOS.
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO.
WILDER.
WALDRON AYE.
GIVE ELEVEN VOTES THE BILL WAS
OUT.
THANK YOU FOR OTHERS TO ADD ON
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I WILL GO BACK AND BACK -- TO
FOR I TO ITEM -- ONE MOVE THE
BILL THANK YOU. FOR THE MOTION.
MOTION BY -- MISS AGUIAR-CURRY A
SECOND BY -- THIS RIO.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WHAT I
WOULD AYE MAYES.
MAYES AYE AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY I BIGELOW
[inaudible]
BONTA.
BONTA AYE BURKE BURKE I CARILLO
CARILLO AYE FLORA FLORA AYE
LIMóN.
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE ROMMEL'S RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE.
THAT'S TWELVE ZERO ITEM NUMBER.
THREE SB FIVE EIGHTY TWO THE
BILL.
I HAVE A MOTION BY MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY A SECOND BY MISS
WALDRON.
THIS IS TO PASS TO A MOTIONS TO
PASSED THE EDUCATION -- MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
WHAT I WOULD AYE MAYES AYE MAYES
AYE AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY
AYE BIGELOW.
BONTA.
BONTA AYE BURKE.
BURKE I CARILLO CARILLO AYE
FLORA FLORA ALONE.
MCCARTY MCCARTY I IN THIS AREA.
NAZARIAN AYE ROMMEL'S.
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON HI. TWELVE TWELVE ZERO
ON THAT AS WELL SO LET'S GO BACK
TO ITEM NUMBER TWO SB FOUR FORTY
FIVE AND OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
LIVE ALONE [inaudible]
RAMOS SANTIAGO [inaudible]
SANTIAGO AYE. TWELVE THAT'S
TWELVE ZERO I THINK.
WE ARE ALL CAUGHT UP NOW SO.
WE WILL LEAVE THE WELL WE'LL
WE'LL WAIT FOR A FEW MINUTES FOR
OUR ARMS ARE ITEM FOR SB.
FIVE EIGHTY NINE LET'S OPEN THE
ROLE ON ITEM FOR SB FIVE EIGHTY
NINE AND CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
BIGELOW.
LIMON RAMOS SANTIAGO.
SOMEHOW I THINK YOU.
SO THAT'S TWELVE ZERO SO WE WILL --
THE WAY FOR A FEW MINUTES WE
HAVE A COUPLE MEMBERS THAT ARE
OUT AND WE HOPE THEY'LL BE ABLE
TO COME IN COME IN VOTE.
SO WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR FIVE
MINUTES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH
SIR CHAIR OF
THE WE ARE GOING TO GO TO SORT
OF THE TOP -- ITEM NUMBER ONE SB
TWELVE PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BIGELOW.
LIMON I LUÍN I THIRTEEN
THIRTEEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER TWO SP
FOUR FORTY FIVE PORTANTINO
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
BIGELOW.
LIMóN I THANK YOU.
SIR.
BIGELOW AYE BIGELOW AYE OKAY Là
MùT.
HI Là M<c.cyan> ÁI [inaudible]</c>
RAMOS. FOURTEEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER
THREE SB FIVE EIGHTY TWO BELL
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE LIMóN AYE LIMON AYE
RAMOS. FOURTEEN FOURTEEN ZERO
ITEM NUMBER FOUR SP -- FIVE
EIGHTY NINE SENATOR BATES PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS BIGELOW AYE BIGELOW AYE
LIMóN AYE LIMON AYE RAMOS.
FOURTEEN THEY WILL GO BACK TO
ITEM NUMBER ONE SB -- TWELVE
ONCE AGAIN WILL OPEN THE ROLL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE.
RAMOS. FOR THE PAST FOURTEEN
ZERO OKAY -- WITH THAT WITH THE
ASENCE OF MISTER -- RAMOS TODAY
THAT.
EVERYBODY HAS VOTED -- AND THAT
MEANS WE WILL GO AHEAD AND CLOSE
THE HEARING THANK YOU VERY MUCH